Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to 'Baldi's Unreal Basics in Education and Learning', now
someone had the great idea and burned the whole school down. (yep GREAT idea)
That was awesome! It needed to go away! 'Baldi's Unreal Multiplayer could be a possibility.' Oh, that's what that was all about
Okay. Well, I don't need multiplayer just yet, I need... (friends?)
to get a life and beat this game. That's what I'm gonna do and that's how I feel about this (oh silly mark)
So I'm gonna do that and I'm gonna have a great time doing it, right? ( i sure aint) I'm stalling enough, I'm gonna play this now
I don't know what the new mechanic is, but I'm sure it'll be fine... (Me: yeah fiiiiiiine)
'Chapter three forget'
Woaw
*Strangely happy music playing*
wow
*Music continues*
Well, this is beautiful!!
But why is it beautiful? (idk story?)
I don't think that this is-
Something's not right here.
Oh God!
Ohh.. No
Waiiit a minute (whats wrong Mark?)
Haang on a second!
How many times do I need to run away from this god damn school?! :/
Oh, no...
Well here I go waddlin' my way down the halls, I'm-
HERE TO BURN THE PLACE DOWN!? (probably)
"Salad"? ( a sal ad?)
Oh no
Not Sahl-ah, oh, shit
*bAONG*
*markiplier noises*
Hey, how you doin'?
Why am I back here? Why would I be back here??
This looks like it's many years after the events of.. Baldi-
Oh, "Best friends forever".. (like you and Playtime ey mark?)
Jump rope girl??
Baldi?
Baldi..
BAoLDI!
I'm much shorter now- this is true to life now!! (woaho)
Baldi , hey Baldi, how, uh..
How you doing there Baldi? Hey Baldi. What are you doing?
Baldi
hey, Baldi!
Oh.. OH, is this fortnite? *markimoo laugh*
Baldi what have uh... have ya got there Baldi? Baldi whatcha..
Okay! Alight! I'm just gonna leave now Bowldi!! *spooped*
You're busy, obviously
I'm just gonna waddle my way out the door. See ya.
Don't let the door hit you where the ass bit ya. (what mark? XD)
oh
Heyy!
Jump rope girl!
Don't know if you ever had a real name..  How you doing? Good to see ya!!!
Umm... How's the family?
How's- how ha- hha- uhh mm, uh- mm
Ho!
*Weird markimoo noises (you subscribed for em)*
*Weird warping noise* WO
WAS THAT GOOD??? WHEY, HEY, HEY!!
HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY, hey, hey, hey, oh shit. Okay. OH :o
GOD, NO.!
HOOLY SHIT! Okay, hard pass, hard pass, Baldi, hard- Oh God, hard pass!! Oh hard pass
Eurruh
Oh, good a playground!  And what exactly am I forgetting?!
Am I forgetting, like, my childhood? Am I forgetting, like, someone I knew in childhood? Am I forgetting about my parents?
I'm forgetting about some horrible traumatic experience, or just like school that I didn't like to go to?
Yeah, probably one and not the other, right? Okay, whatever!
Jump rope girl: Le-et's play
Let's not!!!
Hey
Oh!
Um!
Um!!
UMM!
UMM!! OwO
Uhh
HEY! HI! How you do- how you- listen
YOU DON'T WANNA DO THIS, YOU DON'T WANNA DO THIS!! *Baldi jumpscare* AAAAAAA D:
Fuuck...
Ok...
Baldi, if you could just stay as far away from me as you possibly could I'd greatly appreciate it :/
Same goes for you jumpu ropeu girl! Maybe I'm trying to forget about you!
Ehu.. What's that?
Someone unzipping their fly? What kind of sound effect was that? (their, what?)
Okay, alright, I got that that's good. I feel good about that -I'm guessing that it's just a series of...
glowing white balls that I need to ram my face into... (heh)
And hopefully I'll forget something if I do that, if I smash my head into as m- many white balls as I possibly can (oh mark)
I'm bound to forget something- Oh shit
Jump rope girl: L-l-let's play!
*weird voice* L-l-let's not! Euh god, euhh, EUHH, what's wrong with your eyes?
EUHH, NOOOOUUUU! I WASN'T RUNNING!
Jump Rope Girl: Ready? GO!
Aww, I was right there! Lemme smash my head against the ball!! (still soun's wrong XD)
Okie, there we go.
*markimoo noises intensify* there we go
Shit.. SHEEEEET
Okay, all right *Markimoo noises continue*
I don't know where I am. I don't know where you are! (Its a baldi!) I don't know what you are. But you go away!!
Am I gonna have enough time to run away from you? (am i gonna finish these subs?) I don't know where all these memories are,
I know they have giant pillars of light in the sky, but somethin' tells me that's not gonna help me :x
Okay
I'm definitely not gonna have enough time to get away from Baldi! Cuz' I know for a fact that after I get all six, even
If I do, which I probably won't, I'm gonna have to run back to the beginning, aren't I? (pause anyone?)
*marks alien friends appear*
Hey Baldi, how about you DON'T get faster?
Just throwing that out there!
That's an option if you- if you want that option! Hey, I took the wrong way to go. Okay
Hey, how you doing? Hey Baldi, can you turn the light bulbs out of your eyes and just... stop chasing me?
My eyes are up here. Stop staring at my ass!
Stop staring up my ass and stop staring at my ass
I gotta stop talking about my ass so much! It's like the only thing I ever mentioned about myself in these games!
It's just how much my ass gets slapped by Baldi! And that's never something to.. it's not a polite point of conversation!
So since- I don't know I'm shouting that at you, but just stop...
Just stop looking at my ass. Okay, where's that other one? Over there? Okay, well, hmm, I'm not gonna make that
Alright, cool. Well, this is great. Hey Baldi! Oh shit. Oh you fast? You faster?
You look faster! You lose some weight? Where's your slaps?
Oh sh-
*Mark noises* that's real fast. Okay. Well, um, hmm
*More Markiplier noises*
Okay. All right. I got it. I got it. Yee!
Wait a minute
*Loud fire alarm*
I hate it! Oh, shit! Um, uh,
Fuck, no, no not like this. Okay. No, hang on! Ah FIRE BAD! FIRE BAD!
*Alarm continues*
Okay, all right, okay!
Alright!
We-
I don't think I'm gonna make it. There's a beach ball, I dunno why that hasn't popped yet...
I think it's hot enough in here to roast a... beach ball. Okay, whatever.
Huh. All my fire drill training has told me that I need to stop, drop and roll at this point, but I'm not stopping,
I'm not dropping, and I'm not rolling
How do I stop, drop and roll?
Oh
Euh, okay, could I stop it lock it pop it and drop it? Maybe?
That's always an option!
Okay, whatever. Hey, wait, no, wait, ha. Wait, wait a minute. Wait
OW! I guess it's fine. I guess that's fine. Okay, this is fine. This is fine. This is fine. This is fine
I just burned my nipples off, but that's fine!
Come on hurry!
Okay, I'm gonna make it, I think! I think I'm-
YAY!!
I forgot!!! I forgot it all! YAHOO!
Yeah. Alright! Great! I'm so happy!
Haha! Yeah!
Oh boy! Why did I do that?
Oh shit.
Okay. Well that was... I mean not easier than I expected but that was just about as... as I expected
But let's- there's one more.. here and I want to give it a try just because I don't think it's a separate chapter,
So it's probably not deserving of its own video. So I'm gonna play...
Arcade Mode: Summer Camp! 'Survive for as long as you can while Baldi expects you to keep the fiiiiiire going! Find scattered firewood, avoid bear traps, and keep Baldi happy!'
Oh, yea, there we go, baby!
Remember what you're doing!
*Markimoo noises*
We're going camping, oh, boy, here we go-
I hate this... and me
*Baldi: Let's go camping!!*
Mark: Let's not!!
Wh-
Baldi: Alright, all set, I'll  go set up the bear traps.
Baldi: I want you to keep the fire going
Baldi: Go out into the woods and collect fire wood
Baldi: Then bring it back to refuel the fiiire
Baldi: The bigger the first is, the more points you'll earn!
Baldi: Alright, go for it!
Okay! You got it Baldi!
You go-
You got it! You got- I got 4 pieces of wood...
I don't know how I'm gonna be able to see bear traps in this grass, but okay
Baldi: Wow!
Wow indeed! I don't get a score this time. What's that glowing white in the distance? I'm gonna find out what that is Baldi! Oh!
That's... normal! Yeah, I definitely expect to see a soda machine, a school desk, and a locker sitting in the middle of th-!
Huh noooooooo...
Nooooo...
What are you doing out here, FriEnd! Friend? Friend? Friend?
Oh god, friend, you okay, buddy? Buddy? Buddy, pal! What are you doing?!
Buddy, what are you doing out here?! Okay, well! Oh there is points! Oh, okay. There's points!
Oh, the fire is about to go out. I shouldn't have come over here
Well, you know, c'est la vie, c'est la fleu, c'est la bleu, I don't see any bear traps....
Kay...
HOHhh! Wuh-!? Hu-hey...!
HEY! HEY! LISTEN, IT'S OKAY! I DIDN'T MEAN TO! I'M SORRY! I'M SORRY, BALDI!
I'M SORRY!
LISTEN! IT'S ALL-!
*panicked markimoo babbling*
UUHH... I'VE...
got no excuses at this point... Just come...
D- uhh, listen Baldi...
Listen (x11)
Listen! (x6)
LISTEN! (x3)
LISTEN!!!
*Baldi jumpscare* AAAHHHH!!!
AYYyyy...kay...
Wow
I sure did it! I did it! I'm proud of that! Alright! There we have it! All done
Goody goody gumdrops! I did it!
If there's one thing I did...
...it was it.
*lip smack*
And I did it.
(We'll) leave it at that.
This chapter is not available yet, which frankly for the best.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching, until the next part is released
I will lay this to rest and then Baldi can rest until the official...
Sequel comes out, whenever that will come out. So thank you everybody so much for watching, and as always, I will see you
In the next video.
BUH-BYE!!!
*outro music*